die union ist das geht ab die seekiste
eingeblendet freunde mein neues auto ist
nicht dauerhaft ein neues auto seien
aber ab heute schwer eingebrochen wie
viele außerdem auf gruppen bereits werbe
video eingeblendet dass sie mich daran
als dieses video irgendwie bezahlt
werden oder so sondern ich bekomme halt
dieses kostenlos für eine woche und kann
damit fahren wir wissen gar nicht
welches auto ist sich an der des
allerdings einen porsche sein es wird
ein sehr krasser porsche sein es wird
ein absolutes der zweitling modell von
porsche sollen echte kerle von porsche
gt2 rs super allerdings würde ich sagen
der ist mal wieder der kamera
altehrwürdig ich bin ich richtig nervös
ich würde es lage vor euch jetzt sagen
aber gefahr die jetzt erstmal zum
forschungszentrum köln und schauen was
da auf uns wartet
ich bin
ich bin als wir sitzen in dem wagen
fühle mich wieso dieses kind was sie
sich so ein kleines matchbox auto kauft
und dann über nacht wird zu einem großen
einfach ich werde euch noch nicht jetzt
direkt sagen was ist für ein auto ist
sondern ich würde sagen wir machen
direkt einen carport und da seht ihr
einfach dass hier gerade abgeht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja leute es ist ein marke porsche gt3
die karte hängt so krank am gas
prominenten ich würde sagen wir fahren
jetzt erst mal zum hockenheimring also
ihr seht schon ich habe andere sachen an
da ist auch nicht mehr dave sondern da
ist jetzt findet tatsächlich angekommen
das der grund warum porsche wir unter
anderem diese karte gegeben hat weil am
hockenheimring
gerade geht das alles nicht so die
übelste karte hierhin leider am
hockenheimring ist gerade megatrucks
race event und da fahren wir jetzt
erstmal hin also finde ich uns dieses
monster
[Musik]
wie mir der neues auto gefällt du
findest du dir was ganz tolles zugelegt
angekommen auf der rennstrecke ist ob
man hört schon im hintergrund so ein
bisschen
ich werde euch jetzt einfach mal so ein
paar eindrücke film
die karten stehen jetzt alle auf der
rennstrecke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da hinten ist nur noch halb so groß
freund das war's vom rennen am
hockenheimring und wir sehen uns jetzt
in köln wieder und sind wir auch wieder
nach vier stunden autofahrern angekommen
ja wir hatten ordentlich staub auf jeden
fall will ich dass ich ja der stelle
jetzt auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
das ist mein auto für diese woche ein
neues auto wer geil wäre dass das für
immer wäre aber leider nur noch bis
nächsten donnerstag ein riesiges
riesiges dankeschön noch mal an porsche
für den mega guten tag heute haben
hockenheimring auch ein riesiges
dankeschön dafür dass ich wirklich
dieses autos für eine woche ein neues
auto nennen darf er zum titel gesehen
danach muss sich den leider wieder
abgeben am nächsten donnerstag ihr habt
oben hier die ganze zeit wäre für
eingeblendet gesehen nicht weil dieses
video hier bezahlt worden ist sondern
weil ich halt dieses auto bekommen habe
für eine woche und megageil also ich bin
immer noch hin und weg deswegen leute
falls ihr wollt dass ich eventuell noch
mal ein video in den nächsten tagen in
diesem auto hochladen werde dann last
light da weil wir haben die idee durch
einen mcdonald's mcd zu fahren nicht
noch einmal und ich zwei oder vielleicht
drei vier mal durch den gleichen weg
greift und auf die reaktionen zu warten
von den leuten die dort stehen und die
kunden bedienen was du zu dem auto sagen
und was sie auch dazu sagen dass wieder
mehrmals durchfahren als wir das machen
sollen schreibt uns in die kommentare
lassen weiter und jetzt bin ich traurig
weil ich das auto demnächst abgeben muss
[Musik]